Apple's brand new M2 MacBook Pro has
finally been released but many are
asking the question is it worth spending
the extra cash on the 14-inch M1 Pro
MacBook Pro well in this video we are
going to answer that question by
comparing basically everything between
these two MacBooks including the designs
the displays the speakers the
microphones the ssds and real world
performance and actual tasks that you
guys use all the time and a big one that
I'm personally curious about is actually
the battery life because right here I
have both of them charged up to 100 and
as we run all of our tests throughout
this video we are going to be looking at
how it drains and see how much each one
is left with at the end of the video so
with that said let's go ahead and unplug
both of them and get right into the
comparison now the first thing I want to
mention is the specs of both machines
this is the base M2 MacBook Pro that's
thirteen hundred dollars it comes with
eight gigs of RAM and 256 gigs of SSD
now this one comes with 16 gigs of RAM
and 512 so basically double of each and
it's actually on sale on Amazon for
eighteen hundred dollars right now and
the interesting thing is if you match
the specs of the 14 inch on the base one
you're actually sitting at Seventeen
hundred dollars so if you were to spend
a hundred dollars more for the same
specs and you're willing to get 5 12 and
16 you're basically getting this entire
machine with a lot of different upgrades
as I'm going to show you in this video
so that's definitely something to think
about and you'll find those links in the
description and pin comment below now
before we get into talking about the
displays and the actual performance I
want to close these down and point out
some of the differences on the exterior
now you guys know that the 14 inch has
this brand new redesign that looks
really good with these rounded corners
and a completely flat bottom and top
compared to of course the M2 MacBook Pro
which is basically reusing the same
MacBook Pro Design as the 2 2016 MacBook
Pro so this is definitely dated so if
you're buying this you're buying a
really old design that's basically
getting outdated at this point comparing
the thickness the M2 MacBook Pro is
technically thicker at its thickest
point but because of the chamfer design
it looks a lot thinner compared to the
14 inch which is basically flat on the
top and bottom so it looks really thick
and chunky now in terms of the weight
the 14 inch is half a pound heavier
partially because of the larger design
and larger display but it's also packing
some goodies on the inside as well which
I'm going to get into in just a minute
getting into the ports the M2 MacBook
Pro just has two Thunderbolt 3 ports on
the left side compared to two
Thunderbolt 4 ports on the 14 inch and a
Max save 3 fast charging connector which
I personally love and of course it has
the headphone jack with support for high
impedance headphones and then on the
other side the M2 also gets a high
impedance headphone jack however the
14-inch gets an HDMI port it's actually
2.0 it also gets an SD card slot and
another Thunderbolt 4 Port now to me
those extra ports are a huge deal
because they really do come in handy
especially the HDMI and the SD card slot
because on the M2 you got to use one of
those ports for the actual charging
leaving one left over for whatever else
you want to connect to it so having that
vast amount of ports on the 14 inch is a
huge deal now the next thing I want to
get into is the actual internals because
there are a lot of differences first of
all you can see a lot more events on the
14 inch MacBook Pro right here on the
sides of their events there are three
separate vents on the back right here
compared to the M2 MacBook Pro that just
has the slim vents right in the back and
that's all and speaking of the cooling
systems the M2 MacBook Pro just has a
single fan but the 14 inch has two of
them and they're bigger and thicker and
the heatsinks are larger in the heat
pipes as well well so the whole cooling
system is just beefed up compared to the
M2 and on top of that there is a huge
difference in the speaker systems
because the 14 inch has a six speaker
system compared to just two speakers on
the M2 but a huge difference that we can
see is that on the M2 MacBook Pro there
are two spots for nand SSD chips and
only one of them is being filled
compared to the 14 inch which has four
spots with two of them filled so I'm
going to show you why that is a big deal
in just a minute the trackpads on both
of these MacBooks are almost the same
they feel very similar and they're
basically the best track pads out of any
laptop out there the keyboards are both
really good with the keys on the 14 inch
being a little bit better because they
have a little bit more key travel but
the M2 MacBook Pro is basically the last
MacBook that's going to be coming with
the touch bar so if you like that you
can go with this but I personally like
the entire Hardware function row on the
14 inch and now let's compare the
speakers
[Music]
I don't know about you guys but that was
a massive difference now the speakers on
the M2 MacBook Pro aren't bad but they
sound bad compared to the 14 inch
because these just pack so much bass
mids highs everything all together they
sound amazing compared to the 13 inch
now these are better than a lot of other
Windows laptops but the 14 inch just
kills it now jumping into the webcams
and microphones the 13-inch M2 MacBook
Pro still uses the same 720p webcam as
it did for years but they did kind of
update the software a little bit so
there's more contrast there but check
out how the 14 inch looks right away you
can tell that the image looks more
natural you can see more detail in my
hair it it doesn't look like it's over
sharpened and it does have the 1080p
webcam and it should have better
microphones but you guys be the judge of
that and let me know down in the comment
section below now getting into the
displays there is a huge difference here
first of all the 14 inch MacBook Pro has
that Notch which at First Look it looks
kind of annoying but I have the 16-ish
at home and I've just completely ignored
it I don't really notice it anymore and
I really appreciate the thinner bezels
that come alongside that Notch look at
that the bezel difference is huge
compared to the old M2 13-inch MacBook
Pro those are huge bezels especially at
the top now as far as the actual display
panels themselves the M2 MacBook Pro
uses a regular LCD panel with 500 nits
of brightness but the 14 inch has a mini
LED panel which means that it actually
has different zones where it lights up
that creates more brightness up to 1600
nits Peak and a thousand is sustained
across a full white page which is pretty
amazing not only that but you get deeper
blacks more contrast which means when
you're watching videos at night you
don't have those big gray bars that you
have on the LCD display with the M2 it
looks a lot nicer however with that you
can have the issue of blooming where you
can see a little bit of glow if you have
a really dark image with some bright
spots but overall it is a lot better
especially since you can download the
Vivid app where you can manually
increase the brightness up to a thousand
nits all the time because usually it's
just 500 but with that app you can have
up to a thousand and that app is a
lifesaver if you're going to be using
your MacBook outside now not only that
but the mini LED display is a must if
you're going to be doing HDR photo or
video editing so that's a big bonus but
my favorite part about the 14-inch
MacBook Pros display is 120 hertz Pro
motion support for it which means the
refresh rate is doubled compared to the
M2 which is stuck at 60 hertz all the
time so everything is going to look a
lot smoother including if you're playing
some games at up to 120 hertz now with
all of that out of the way let's go
ahead and jump into all of our
performance testing starting off with an
SSD speed test we have Blackmagic open
right here so let's go ahead and run it
and wow this is absolutely insane the
write speed on the 14 inches almost
three times faster 4 000 compared to
around 1400 megabytes per second and the
read speed is 3.6 times faster on the 14
inch 5400 compared to 1500 now the main
reason is because one of the spots for
the SSD nand chips is empty on the M2
whereas the 14 inch has four total spots
with two of them being populated so
because of that the speeds are
drastically reduced on this base 256 gig
model now if you get the 512 gig of the
M2 it actually goes up to around 2200
for the right and 2900 for the read
which is still a lot slower than this
512 gig M1 Pro and now let's move on to
a geekbench 5. the first thing I'm going
to do is the CPU test but I want to
mention that the M2 Chip is running at
3.49 gigahertz that's the speed of the
high performance cores compared to 3.22
on the M1 Pro so there's a good chance
that the M2 is going to have faster
single core performance but let's test
it out we got our scores and this is
actually very interesting in terms of
the multi-core performance the 14 inch
with the bend eight core CPU is 12
faster and that's across a wide variety
of tasks and not necessarily a full 100
load which we're going to test out in
just a minute but going over to the
single core the M2 is actually now nine
percent faster than the M1 Pro and
that's because it has the newer cores
that are putting in more clock speed and
that's going to help the whole system
feel more Snappy if you're not maxing
out the ram now that boost in single
core performance should actually help
web browsing performance as well so
let's run speedometer 2.0 and look at
that we have a score of 402 runs per
minute on the M2 which is a
record-breaking score faster than
basically any consumer laptop or
computer out there and it's actually 39
faster than the M1 Pro which is shocking
because a single core performance was
only nine percent faster so web browsing
is going to be insanely smooth and
snappy on the M2 now moving on to the
graphics side this M2 MacBook Pro has a
10 core GPU compared to the Bend 14 core
GPU on the M1 Pro and here we have our
scores we have 39 000 for the M1 Pro and
30 000 for the m into that's 29 faster
on the Bend 14 core M1 Pro now moving on
to a more realistic gaming Benchmark
this is 3dmarks wildlife extreme
unlimited mode which means it's off
screen let's go ahead and run this and
see a more realistic type of workload
all right we have our scores we have
55.4 FPS for the M1 Pro and 41 for the
M2 now this is actually a bigger
difference 35 faster on the M1 Pro so
this is going to help for a variety of
tasks especially for gaming and now
let's move on to the CPU stress test
running cinebench R23 this is going to
be the 10 minute test but before I get
into that I want to do an initial
thermal reading with our seek thermal
camera now over on the M2 MacBook Pro
you can see that we're idling at around
29 degrees Celsius 28 right there and
going over to the 14 inch it's the same
29 9 degrees actually right there at the
top where the heat vents are at now what
I have opened right over here to the
left is the power metrics this is an app
called acetop which is very handy so
we're going to use that to track the
frequencies and the wattage so let's go
ahead and start our multi-core test
right off the bat we're seeing the temps
shoot up on the M2 we're sitting at 82
degrees Celsius on the CPU 84 compared
to 74 on the M1 Pro now in terms of the
wattage the M2 sitting at around 19.5
Watts being used compared to around 22
Watts on the M1 Pro so it's not using
that much more power but in terms of the
peak it looks like the M2 hit
23.7 watts compared to 24 Watts on the
M1 Pro so it's literally right next to
it in terms of peak wattage and in terms
of the actual frequencies we're sitting
at around three gigahertz for the M1 Pro
and 3 0.2 gigahertz for the M2 and in
terms of the fan speed it looks like the
M2 is running a little bit faster we're
sitting at 2600 RPMs compared to around
2300 2500 for both of the fans on the M1
Pro and now the M2 is really starting to
heat up we're sitting at 96 degrees
Celsius for the CPU compared to 92 on
the M1 Pro so it's staying a little bit
cooler so what I'm going to do is let
this run until the end of the test and
we'll come back with some updates now
looking at the actual cores themselves
it looks like some of the performance
cores on the M2 are reaching over a
hundred degrees Celsius 101 right there
compared to the M1 Pro looks like the
hottest performance course sitting at
around 95. actually I just checked into
a set to the average CPU temperature I
just wished it to highest and I saw it
go 102 right there look at that 102. we
actually had it hit as high as 104 105
in the past and the crazy thing is I
haven't and seen the M1 Pro go above 97
degrees at all even though the fans are
spinning slower than the M2 which is
sitting at almost 4 000 RPMs compared to
around 3 000 average on the M1 Pro
alright so we're past nine minutes into
the test I want to give you guys an
update with the thermal camera let's
look over at the M2 MacBook Pro and we
have a huge heat spot right there I saw
it hit 41 degrees Celsius 40 right now
on the M2 and on the M1 Pro
44 degrees Celsius so the actual area
near the chip is hotter on the M1 Pro
and the reason the M1 Pro is showing 44
degrees Celsius is because the cooling
system is more efficient so it's pulling
more heat from the actual chip itself
allowing the ship to run cooler which
means that you're going to have less
issues with heat on the chip and less
fan noise as well and there you go the
Tesla's finish and the M1 Pro is scoring
9.5 percent High higher than the M2
while using around 13 percent more
average wattage than the M2 and now
let's move on to our xcode programming
test which is going to give you a good
idea of how much performance you're
getting for different programming tasks
and to do this we're going to do the
xcode Benchmark and we have our scores
it looks like we have 119 seconds on the
M2 and 108.5 on the M1 Pro so in reality
the M1 Pro isn't that much faster but if
you really need as much performance as
you can get there's also the unbend 10
core model of the M1 Pro if you pay a
couple hundred dollars more and now
let's move on to the logic pro Benchmark
which basically puts a stress test load
onto the CPU to see how many tracks it
can handle playing at once before
overloading the system and as you can
see the M1 Pro is currently running
135 tracks while we just failed trying
to run 80 on the M2 now this has barely
improved compared to the M1 model for
some reason I personally think it's
because they tried to push the clock
speeds more on the M2 Chip so that's why
it might not be as stable so what I did
is I turned the tracks down to 78 on the
M2 but it's still overloaded before
finishing one Loop which is unfortunate
so I'm going to take one away let's try
77 while the M pro has been running
135 tracks with multiple Loops right now
with no issues so it's definitely the
better laptop for music production now
if you want to choose the M2 model then
you should probably be getting 16
gigabytes of RAM at a minimum if you're
going to be using a lot of plugins and
now let's move on to testing photo
editing in Lightroom classic the first
thing I'm going to do is cycle through
some photos to see which one switches
quicker
and so far
it looks like the M1 Pro is actually
consistently switching to the next photo
quicker than the M2 and that's likely
because the SSD is so much faster on the
14-inch MacBook Pro and now what I'm
going to do is export these 50 raw 42
megapixel photos on both of these
machines and I do want to mention that
we don't have any background tasks that
are using up the ram because in our
previous video we loaded up on the RAM
and we noticed because of the slower SSD
on the M2 it did impact the performance
negatively so keep that in mind but
let's go ahead and Export these the M1
Pro is blasting through it's almost done
already which is crazy because the M2
isn't even 50 percent done at this point
there you go the M1 Pro just finished
and now we got to wait on the M2 so the
M1 Pro flew through that test and we
were wondering why there was such a big
difference and we noticed in the
settings there's a new GPU acceleration
option and the M1 Pro had it
automatically turned on to use the GPU
for export but the M2 did not so we went
ahead and turned it on and now let's
retest it alright guys this is really
weird because we re-ran it with the GPU
turned on and the M2 barely improved it
went from two minutes and seven seconds
to two minutes and two seconds with GPU
acceleration turned on while the M1 Pro
finished in 55 seconds blazing fast now
this is really weird because the M2
barely improved and I think it's because
of the ram being a limitation with the
eight gigs potentially being slowed down
by the slow SSD speeds I'm not sure but
we are going to be doing a full
dedicated video with two versions of the
M2 MacBook Pro one with eight gigs and
one with 16 gigs of RAM to see what
differences we can find with that Ram
difference and now I want to test
Affinity photo because it has a built-in
Benchmark that is very optimized for
metal and we have our scores it looks
like the GPU is 30 faster and the CPU is
15 faster so a pretty good improvement
with the M1 Pro and now for those of you
who like to use Photoshop we're going to
go ahead and do an HDR test basically
combining nine different photos into one
to see which one does it faster bam the
M1 Pro just finished still waiting on
the M2 and there you go the m2s finished
looks like we have around 13 seconds for
the M1 Pro to load up that HDR scene and
20 seconds for the M2 that is a huge
difference 54 faster on the M1 Pro so if
you're doing this all the time like a
lot of photographers are that's going to
be a huge deal for you and now moving on
to video editing in Final Cut Pro we're
going to start off with a fairly easy
test this is a 4K
h.265 hevc file now playing it back both
of them have no problem at all this is
actually with two Luts and and film
grain so some added effects and as you
can see there's really no difference
between the two so if you're doing
common stuff like this you're really not
going to see that big of a difference so
let me go ahead and Export this five
minute clip all right now this is
actually very good news the M2 is
pulling ahead of the M1 Pro now neither
of them are using a ton of resources
that means they're both limited by the
encoders so it does look like the new
encoders and decoders on the M2 are
improved even faster than the encoders
on the M1 Pro and there you go it looks
like the M2 finished in two minutes and
20 seconds while the M1 Pro finished in
two minutes and 25 so just a little bit
slower than the M2 now that is awesome
news because this is a less expensive
machine and you're getting slightly
faster video editing but keep in mind
that this is actually with not that many
effects or hard footage this is very
simple hvc 4K so let's go ahead and do a
more stressful test and another nice
thing about the M2 Chip is that it also
has a prores engine whereas the M1
didn't so it better matches up to the M1
Pro so let me go ahead and play this
footage this is prores raw it says a
five minute timeline so for those of you
who are wondering if the M2 can decode
prores raw it looks like it can because
as you can see the CPU usage is very low
it's staying at around 14 which means
that the prores media engine is working
on this prores raw footage and while
this footage is playing I can definitely
tell that the M1 Pro is using less of
the GPU to process this footage compared
to the M2 which is using around 79 so
that means that the M1 Pro is going to
have a little bit more wiggle room to
add some more effects while still having
smooth playback and now let's export
this five minute clip and there you go
the M2 has finally finished and wow that
is a huge difference the M1 Pro finish
in a minute and seven seconds and the M2
finished in two minutes and 14 so
exactly twice as long and that is
because the prores engines are so fast
that both machines are GPU limited and
of course the GPU on the M1 Pro is
faster but it also looks like we might
be dealing with some differences in
potentially the SSD speed or maybe the
ram as well and keep in mind this is
just with Final Cut open if we add more
tabs more apps there is going to be more
slowdowns with this M2 machine because
of that slow SSD and now let's test out
some really tough footage this is 8k
Cannon raw in a 4K timeline five minutes
once again so let's go ahead and Export
it guys this is insane I just saw 107
degrees Celsius on the M2 MacBook Pro
looks like the M1 Pro is 103 108 degrees
Celsius on the CPU on the M2 that is
absolutely insane this is definitely
some very tough footage it's maxing
everything out the CPU and the GPU
GE stress on both of them 108 degrees
Celsius I'm starting to hear the fans
the M1 Pro is already at 5000 RPMs the
M2 is catching up 4 900 right now yep
there you go 5000 as well I could
definitely hear that it's a little bit
louder on the M1 Pro side this is crazy
this is putting an extreme load on both
of these MacBooks the fan on the M2 is
maxed out 7 200 RPMs it is loud a little
bit lower on the M1 Pro look at that
5800 5300 on the M1 Pro alright so now
the test has finished and the fans have
cooled down and we made some crazy
discoveries first of all the M1 Pro
finished in 11 minutes and 21 seconds
while the M2 finished in 19 minutes and
40 seconds significantly slower not only
that but we decided to run acetop while
it was running and take a look at the
wattage and the the frequencies and we
made a crazy Discovery first of all the
M1 Pro was able to stay at 100 CPU and
GPU basically the entire time without
any glitches or stutters however the M2
Chip it was overheating like mad it was
hitting up to 108 degrees Celsius while
the fan was completely maxed out 7 200
RPMs without stopping however what we
noticed was it would drop down from
around 100 and 508 degrees all the way
down to the 80s in terms of the CPU
temperature so we looked into it and it
was basically cutting off the CPU going
down to under four Watts used for the
CPU which basically shows that this fan
in the M2 is not enough to cool down the
M2 Chip it did everything it can maxing
out the fans but it wasn't enough so it
forced the CPU down significantly just
to cool it down before going into
another wave of maxing out the chair now
the M1 Pro did not have any of those
issues it was able to run at full
performance and the fans weren't even
maxed out like they were on the M2 so
basically Apple needed to put a better
cooling system or a bigger fan in the M2
MacBook Pro but of course they didn't
because they decided not to change
anything about the design so with all
that testing now out of the way before I
reveal the final battery life
differences I do want to mention that
Max is going to be doing a full video
editing comparison going through Final
Cut DaVinci Resolve and Premiere Pro
going in depth with the M2 Chip and
comparing it to the M1 Pro so definitely
subscribe if you want to see that and
now for the Moment of Truth the battery
life I want to First mention that we
started filming at around 9 45 and now
it's 2 13 so just about about four and a
half hours of filming and testing
performance testing everything and let's
take a look we have the M2 MacBook Pro
at 29 battery life and the M1 Pro is at
17 battery life so it's not that big of
a difference especially if you look at
Apple's website and it seems like the M2
gets a lot more battery life so in
reality it seems like you're going to be
getting about an extra hour of battery
life with the M2 MacBook Pro if you're
using your MacBook for performance tax
and don't forget that the M1 Pro also
has Max save 3 so it's going to be
charging about twice as fast as the M2
MacBook Pro So based on all those tests
here are my personal recommendations
well first of all if you're planning on
already getting 16 gigs of RAM or 512
gigs for the SSD you can pay just a
hundred dollars more 1800 bucks for the
M1 Pro MacBook Pro on Amazon right now
on sale using the link below I would
definitely recommend that because as
there are just so many ways that the M1
Pro is better than the M2 you have the
faster SSD much faster performance you
have the new design all the ports
basically everything about it including
the display is just a much better
machine for just a hundred dollars at
those specs and if you're not going to
push your MacBook that hard then I would
honestly just recommend going with the
M2 MacBook Air because you can get it
for a cheaper price and you have the new
features with the redesign and Max save
3 so I'd say the M2 MacBook Air is a
better choice for those who aren't going
all out on performance so thank you guys
for watching and if you want to see how
the M2 MacBook Pro will perform with 16
gigs of RAM compared to eight then
definitely click the circle about to
subscribe because that video is coming
up very soon and check out one of those
two right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign